انضم الينا من البنتاجون على عقيده
فاترايدر المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه اهلا بك سيد بات سيد بات ما
الذي دفع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى
حسم موقفها باتجاه امداد اوكرانيا بدبابات
ابرامز
شكرا شكرا
كما تعلمون
فان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحلفاءنا
الدوليون وشركاء هنا تعمل بتعاون وثيق معه
اوكرانيا ونعمل سوريه خلال كل فتره الحرب
والغزو الروسي غير المشروع الركنيه لنعرف
اوكرانيا ونقدم لها المساعدات العسكريه
ولو نظر الوضع الحالي في الساحات المعارك
ونرى ان ال- ال- المساعدات الطلبات رانيا
للمساعدات الامنيه درسنا انواع القدرات
التي يحتاجونها ليس فقط للدفاع عن اراضيهم
بل ايضا الاستعاده اراضيهم التي ياخذها
وبالتالي قرار
تعلق بزياده الجويه
وما اوكرانيا قبل ان يتخذ هذا القرار بت
تقديم هذه الدبابات ام واحد لاعطائهم هذه
الميزه في ساحات المعارك من المهم ان نفهم
بان سنقدم دبابات جديده من نوعين واحد
وهذه تكون خارجه من المعمل
التدريب على هذه الدبابات
وتوفيق كل اللوجستيات اللازمه لتشغيل مثل
هذه الدبابات المتقدمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت لديها
مخاوف من امداد اوكرانيا باسلحه هجوميه
وهذا تبدل كيف تبدل الامر يعني ما الذي
اختلف الان
والله
مستمر مع اوكرانيا ومع حلفائنا الدوليين
والشركاء هنا عندما يتعلق مساعدات الامنيه
التي نقدمها لذلك عندما ننظر الى الوضع في
ساحه المعركه حاليا هناك بعض القدرات التي
يحتاجها الاوكرانيين فورا ليستطيع
مواجهه اي عدوان الامريكيه الروسيه
المستمر وايضا الاستعداد استرداد اراضيهم
وبالتالي فان الدبابات
المتحده مهمه جدا لان هذه الدبابات موجوده
في اوروبا
ولكن ايضا مهم ان النظر الى احتياجات
اوكرانيا
الطويل والمتوسط
الدوره الدبابات ايه واحد وبالتالي مره
اخرى استخدم هذا الوقت المتوفر لان لحين
انتاج هذه الدبابه المساعده على التدريب
الاوكرانيين على طريقه استخدامها وايضا
بشكل مهم كيفيه بناء والاستمرار شبكات
اللوجستيه اللازمه لها
شوفوا ماذا يعني ذلك شهرين ثلاثه اكثر
نعم لا ليس لدي
جدول زمني محدد اقدمه لهذا الامر لكن نحن
نقوم بانتاج دبابات
القادمه
انما ينقل المعركه الى مستوى اعلى هل انتم
مستعدون لذلك
انا انا اقلب الامر على العكس واقول بان
هذه حرب اختارتها روسيا فاروسيا هي التي
قررت ان تقوم بطريقه غير مبرره بشكل غنيه
بغزوه اوكرانيا
الديمقراطيه ذات السياده
هل هذا هو العدد النهائي ام ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مستعده لمناقشه امداد
اوكرانيا بالمزيد من هذه الدبابات
ليس لدي اي اعلان جديدكم به اليوم كما
يمكن ان تفهمه موقفي نحن نركز على ما
اعلناه اليوم كم اود ان الصلاه الضوء على
اننا ايضا ومؤخرا قمنا باعلان حول القدرات
دروع اخرى مثل العجلات
واذا كان لدينا اي اعلان جديد نقوم بذلك
هل هي قادره على مواجهه الدبابات الروسيه
والصواريخ الروسيه خاصه باننا شاهدنا
اليوم تدريبات على صواريخ فائقه السرعه من
قبل روسيا فائقه الصوت
يا سعود
الدبابات ام واحد دبابات ذات قطرات عاليه
جدا ويوفقه اكثر دبابه تقدما تطور في
العالم واما اللقب دواء ايضا دبابات ذات
قدراتي متطوره وسيصل مساحه المعركه في
المستقبل القريب ولكن المهمه لا نركز
بالضروره
طريقه طريقه استخدامها هذه الدبابات ضمن
مجموعه اخرى من الاسلحه اين تتحدثنا عن
سلاح المشاه عن الدبابات عن الدعم الجوي
كلها
لتغيير المعادله على ساحه المعركه ليس فقط
الدفاع الراضي
المنوبه
كيف يمكن لا مئه تستخدم هذه القدرات وهذه
المعدات افضل طريقه لاستعاده اراضيهم
العقيد بات رايدر المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه شكرا لك